I found that since the bylaw was
passed by the council and came into
operation, that the vehicles on the beach
have gone down considerably. You rarely
see a vehicle on the beach now, so people are really buying into it
and already we're seeing an improvement
so yeah it's been good. And we'll carry on
you know, we have to carry on, to keep
the word up and not let it lapse so
that goes back to what it was like in past times.
And I think while ECAN and its
rangers have probably most important
role in terms of explaining and educating
getting that information out, that there's lots of other groups we have residents
associations or community board or
whatnot but we have to support them we
shoulder some of that burden and feed
that information out into the sort of
networks that we work and operate in.
We've got to consult with each other
and talk with each other and
come to an arrangement that works for
everybody and I think that's the
implementation process, is what that's
about.
There's a conversation in trying to work
out how we can all exist and coexist
together for the harmony of all.
I agree and it's about getting all users to buy into it,
for the benefit of all.
It is recognising just how special this
area is and we forget each of us
are talking about things that we see as
being important,
but it is a very very special area.
It is, it's a taonga, a treasure, and a part of that is educating all
recreational users about the specialness to each and every one of us and how we see it.